this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery of the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's going to be taking a look
at another title from the battlefield
franchise
2018's battlefield 5. there is one
glaring emission that's this bit
we see at one point there there is no
trigger on this weapon
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to battlefield we've got a
video all about the various guns of
battlefield 1
so make sure to check that out and if
there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down do let us know in
the comment section down below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and click that little bell icon to get
notified when each video goes live and
if you want to help out the royal armies
museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
okay paul's there our old friend the m1
rifle
the garand the yeah the rifle's pretty
well represented
first thing i noticed of course is the
anachronistic
optical sight nothing like that was ever
screwed to the side of a
drilled and tapped m1 as far as i know
we need some some points i think for the
the way the um distressed finish looks
on that particular set of textures i
think
it has a good sort of look to it having
said that actual soldiers
in that time period and that setting
would never decorate their rifle in that
way
and if they did they'd be up on a charge
but of course we're not this is not a uh
us army simulator this is a first person
multiplayer shooter
we saw the the complete reload there
where the
operating rod is the charging handle is
pulled
straight back and the clip with whatever
rounds are remaining in it goes
flying out of the gun that's what would
happen if you did that there is a method
of topping up the on block
clip that's held inside the garand but
to be fair it is quite fiddly to pull
off and i'm not sure that any soldier
would have been doing that in the field
anyway the difference with real life of
course is that those rounds are gone
you can't get them back so what you
would do is
eject the partial clip under control put
that somewhere safe
in a pouch and then load a full clip and
if you are
actually in the middle of a firefight i
don't think you're gonna be doing that
if you do
you're gonna be doing it behind cover
stop that this is a nice one i think for
me as a
a british um firearms historian for
wanting a better term to see the boys in
a in a game it's been in a few i think
but um this is probably the most
prominent appearance and i've not seen
anything
wrong with it if we're nitpicking you
can see an example behind me
so it's got almost a bit bran
reminiscent just
simple iron sights offset to the side
due to the top mounted magazine
a feature that um i suspect my my aging
eyes are too
too rubbish to spot here the real boys
has a sprung recoiling barrelled action
so it's got a chassis essentially and
within that
is the barreled action and that whole
thing
recoils against a very strong spring and
it's that
plus the big teacup size muzzle break on
the front
that tames the recoil enough to be able
to fire this thing at all
and that's the take-home message of this
um or any implementation in a video game
of the boys
it's not a barrett whereas with the
barrett you can actually fire that from
the shoulder if you're strong enough to
hold it up
on on the point of aim you can fire it
from the shoulder you can't do that with
the boys
and there's not enough slowing down of
the recoil impulse
to prevent you from at least stumbling
backwards if you fire this thing from
the shoulder so you'd need to be a
serious
unit to be able to run and gun with this
thing and i'm not sure it would even be
possible
if it was i very much doubt you'd hit
anything you were aiming at
it's it's incredibly heavy it was a
struggle for me to put it on the table
but then i have a tiny curator arms so
uh
good lord i think i've just seen what
happens when a mexican drug cartel gets
its hands on
time travel technology because that that
gold
black finish is uh pretty horrific
i like to think it would horrify a
german soldier of the period as well
we're looking of course at the the stern
gover
mp43 mp44 sdg44 with that
horrific finish on it and another
nonsense optical sight
i think what annoys me about those the
most is that they seem to be a default
if you're going to start surely you want
to start with the iron sights and then
upgrade to the made up
optics anyway i'm starting to sound like
i want them to get off my lawn
so i'll stop talking
of course i never have never got on with
the battlefield in the wonderback of
five with the with the air combat but
if i was in an aircraft taken out by
that collection of
pipes i think i'd be pretty upset
especially there's a one-shot kill
we've got here another weapon that we
don't have in the royal army's
collection which makes me sad
the fleega faust it's quite ingenious as
a lot of weapons in
second world war were and it really is
just a
bunch of pipes because it's a rocket
launcher
and um the concept which is pretty
genius really was um
20 millimeter cannon projectiles which
explode
when you hit an aircraft anyway with a
rocket motor grafted to the
back end of them and they they all
projectiles and it did in fact load in
the way that
that is seen with sort of the
contraption that holds those rounds
together
shove that into the end and then
electrical ignition
to send them on their way down the pipes
and toward the aircraft
i gather it wasn't hugely successful i
can't think why it seems to work
perfectly well
in battlefield 5.
what they're calling the lunge mine
which i think is a loose translation
translation of japanese because this is
a
very much a last ditch weapon japan
being on the the losing end of the war
in 1945
along with germany had a number of last
stitch weapons be it cheaper rifles
even cheaper rifles reverting to sort of
jam tin
bombs grenades things like that this
thing is very much one of those
because it uses the same shaped charge
warhead principle that
things like the piat did an impact to
set off a fuse and then
converting a disc of metal into
super high energy particles that
punch through quite a lot of armor
putting one on the end of a stick
and poking a tank with it seems like the
bottom of my bucket list
to be honest i can imagine a few things
i'd like to do less
than try to bayonet a tank
[Applause]
okay next up we've got bergman mp28
ii submachine gun it looks pretty good i
did notice the
difference with the the rear sight
aperture on the real one here it's
extremely small and v-shaped
the version of the sight in the game is
significantly
larger and more u-shaped there is one
glaring emission
from this video game version of the mp28
ii that's this bit
the bang switch as it's sometimes known
or trigger if you prefer
this this model i don't know if it's
glitch or what but it
we see at one point there there is no
trigger on this weapon
well it would still work in theory but
it's not really very effective
all right pause that the most effective
machine guns machine guns are
truly useful for fire support and being
a base of fire for a unit
are belt fed there are very few
exceptions to that one of them
is the japanese type 11 which is what we
see here
it's like a lot of japanese weapons to
westernize anyway it's very distinctive
in its look part of that is to do with
how it works and it
ignores the belt feed ignores box
magazines and it goes for something that
you would assume was experimental but
this was actually widely issued
in brief it works as it does in the game
you lift up the
um i guess you'd call it a follower
except it's on top
and the the clever aspect of this system
it's a hopper
so we we're used to that from things
like the old gatling gun
uh with gravity feed this has a spring
assist and
critically it uses five round arisaka
rifle clips so you don't have to worry
about the logistics of a magazine
to know whether it was a really success
or not but the fact that it was not
sort of gone with later or no other
nations have gone with this
suggests that the logistical advantages
are not worth
the reduction in effective rate of fire
because actually being able to just
top it off by throwing in more clips
seems like a very efficient way of
working
that's the only firearm that i'm aware
of that uses a system quite like that
which means it adds
a nice bit of variety for the player
this beast which feels substantially
heavier than it looks in the game if
that makes any kind of sense at all
is the the suomi uh kp31 now the one
i've got here is fitted with
the this is a later example which
matches
the model used in the game it's fitted
with the uh
40 round drum magazine there's a 71
round drum magazine as well
poor saps in the game are stuck with a
20 round
box magazine which was was in common use
so it's not
it's not as though it's wrong or
anything but if you had the choice you
would want
the drum magazine because this design of
drum which was copied by the russians as
well
is one of the better drum magazines ever
designed
it means that really high rate of fire
which is faithfully represented in the
game
doesn't just run you out of ammunition
in the blink of an eye you can actually
start to
walk shots onto the target by
observing where your bullets are
striking i can't recall or possibly
haven't ever played this in battlefield
5 i can't remember
but in theory it would be more
controllable due to the compensator
ports that are
designed into the barrel at the end of
the barrel shroud i should say
and those are on the game model and it
didn't look like we're getting too much
dispersion
from the design
okay now this is a really interesting
inclusion in the game
the the m3 carbine which is the gun and
this
the hilariously named sniper scope uh
this is
about the furthest thing from a sniping
weapon that you could imagine
but that's what it was called and this
is a a generation one night vision
device
in modern terminology so this this is
pretty well represented in the game as
far as the model goes
the elephant in the room is this bit
because that has to be attached to an
enormous car battery
truck battery which we don't have here
we have several sets of these
because the americans couldn't see the
use for these
and i don't know that i blame them and
um handed them over to the brits
and we had some interesting support for
that theory i suppose
when i received a call a few years ago
from a british korean war veteran who
told me about being issued these things
and
not knowing what the hell they were at
first and essentially you'd be
crouched in a bush waiting for a green
blob to float
past the green blob that was your view
because it's
not like the game with that relatively
crisp grayish view
well for all i know it is grey but um
from what i understand it would be more
of a green color
certainly you wouldn't be able to
discern a person beyond
i don't know 50 yards 50 meters
something like that i guess within that
distance within that very short distance
this was a sort of sniper weapon because
you were one
person one soldier trying to score a
kill
with a scope so it's sort of a sniper
weapon but not really
and last up we have the american
liberator pistol
this is was much more of a psychological
weapon than it was
a real weapon it is a real weapon it is
deadly but it was
so crude and so slow to reload which we
definitely do get from
from watching the game that it really
was fit only for capturing a better
weapon
in reality it was much more it was much
more use
in terms of denting the the morale of
the nazis by dropping these with their
leaflet their instruction leaflet in
their box
we have a box here which is tied up with
strings not in the best condition
but it has a picture of what it is on
the outside it does work much like
in the game except that when you pull
this back there's not some
feature inside that holds it to the rear
which is what i see
what i see in the um gameplay you have
to rest the striker
on the actual body of the gun so it sits
much further forward than is depicted on
the model
in the game unrivaled very short barrel
so in some ways the
the low damage that we see in the game
is sort of realistic because this is
nowhere near its ballistic potential
but at the same time it's still going
fast enough at these ranges
to create a 45 caliber hole in your body
which is exactly what a 1911 would do
accuracy would be awful i know people
have shot these and they are
they're pretty much what you'd expect
not very accurate but good enough for
the sort of
10 meters that a pistol is typically
used at
we've got links in the description if
you'd like to donate to
the museum to the royal armouries i've
also got my book
on british ballpark firearms which is
available now so check that out if you'd
like but
in any case thanks very much
[Music]
you